there's a little bit of a rehabilitation
of melania trump that's happening and
the latest attempt at this is
um the claim from a forthcoming book
that melania slammed trump for his
dealing with covet early in the pandemic
when trump was still president you're
blowing this is the quote that is in
this new book there's a cnn article
about this by kevin liptak which you can
read in a couple of minutes uh trump's
top general
feared he would authorize a strike on
iran as his presidency ended his
intelligence chief wondered what russia
had on him a billionaire friend
convinced him to try buying greenland a
half dozen top officials considered
resigning in mass even his wife first
lady melania was quote rattled by the
coronavirus and convinced that trump was
screwing up
according to a forthcoming book from the
new york times chief white house
correspondent peter baker and new yorker
staff writer susan glasser set to
publish next tuesday
in a phone call with former new jersey
governor chris christie
melania trump sought help convincing her
husband to take the pandemic more
seriously you're blowing this she
recalled telling her husband the
author's right this is serious it's
going to be really bad and you need to
take it more seriously than you're
taking it he had just dismissed her you
worry too much she remembered him saying
forget it
so
this really does very little positive
for melania trump's image and what i
mean by that is
everyone at the time knew that trump was
blowing it everybody knew that trump was
blowing it was it was absurd trump's
handling of the coronavirus pandemic was
pathetic remember saying 15 cases will
soon be zero
would a flu shot prevent covid
all of it okay he completely blew it and
everybody knew it and uh it was clear at
the time
melania trump didn't come out and
publicly say a word about this
this doesn't absolve her of anything now
i understand
is it reasonable to expect the first
lady to come out and publicly say
my husband is blowing this no but the
point is it's no great
feat that we now find out that she
thought he was blowing it at the time
everybody thought that trump was blowing
it at the time and you could actually
argue it's worse she knew how bad it was
and nothing was done
um trump's handling of kovid and i think
this is the most important takeaway now
in retrospect was a failure not just
medically obviously it was a failure
medically it was arguably one of trump's
biggest political failures
trump could have easily sailed to
reelection if from the start of the
pandemic he said
we are going to beat this back better
than any other country we're going to
wear
mega masks he could have monetized the
maga medical masks
we are the ultimate patriots with our
mega masks stopping kobit we're going to
listen to doctors and we are going to be
the best at this let's do it
and then he would have sailed to
re-election and we know that it would
have worked because it worked in other
countries there are a number of other
world leaders who had re-election
campaigns during the pandemic in the
earlier phase of the pandemic they did
handle it properly the country rallied
around them and they easily won
re-election and trump could have so for
all of the blaming that now is done in
retrospect oh the it was the problem was
they they stole it with uh mail-in
ballots and massive dumps in the middle
of the night and all of this stuff
trump could have easily won reelection
simply by taking the
we are the patriots of all patriots
by dealing with this as seriously as
other countries
and trump would be president right now
so great melania knew what everybody
knew trump was completely blowing
coveted
uh we're not going to give her a cookie
no
more on these stories on our instagram
which you can find at david pakman show
we'll take a quick break and be right
back
i know that many of you who watch this
show also love documentaries if you
don't have curiosity stream you were
missing out our sponsor curiosity stream
is the only streaming platform
specializing in documentaries that's all
they have documentaries and this lets
them deliver the newest and most
critically acclaimed documentaries stuff
you're not going to find on other
streaming services curiosity stream also
has a whole bunch of super high quality
original content you won't find anywhere
else the other night i watched asteroids
comets and meteors as many of you know
i'm super interested in what seems to be
the
inevitable direction we are going which
is the eventual mining of asteroids and
to be perfectly frank i never remember
the difference between asteroids comets
and meteors and that's one of the things
that i learned check out curiosity
streams catalog you'll see they have a
much better selection of documentaries
and the other platforms they also have
an app for your tv phone tablet and
computer and the best part is my
audience gets curiosity stream for under
two bucks a month when you go to
curiositystream.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below